-Ah, double death.
-Nope!
Was that...
I think we're both...no you killed me!
-I think you died under me!
-You killed me!
Haha!
I'm Michael Jonathan Smith.
I'm the showrunner of Twisted Metal.
And we're gonna be playing
Twisted Metal: Black™
from 2001 on the PS4.
Now we're gonna choose characters.
-There's John Doe.
-John Doe, use caution
nice, nice, nice.
Looks different.
Yeah.
It's the gun.
-The gun is different.
-The gun.
-The gun is...
-Yeah.
Same eyebrows.
I grew up not a huge gamer,
but playing a lot of, uh like
kiddie games. My mom and I would play
Atari and stuff like that together.
So, when anybody in the neighborhood
got a PlayStation it was a big deal.
Hahahaha!
Did you just explode Anthony?
-Yeah.
-Anthony's dead.
Our apocalypse happened in 2002.
I wanted to do that because
the 90s and 2000s was like when
these games came out
and that's just so synonymous,
for me at least, with the time.
Hahahaha!
You almost got us killed for a
bunch of stupid CDs?
Stupid CDs?
Good music is worth its
weight in gold nowadays.
I got my first car around 2002
and I loved playing my CDs and driving.
So, I have a few scenes where
I'm on the highway, jamming out,
that's my favorite thing.
What about you, Stephanie?
I didn't learn to drive in high school.
I just didn't learn,
but I did ride passenger
-with all of my friends.
-Funny.
The seat that I have in this show
was what I was doing.
I was helping navigate,
I was along for the ride.
It'd be great if you could warn me before you drift like that.
I f***ing slammed my g*****n
head into the window.
I said, "Hang on."
Was there a stunt thing
that you were like
really wanted to do and
were excited to do?
Yeah, that fight!
That fight that I got to do.
That fight was awesome.
Because I like just stood there and
watched everything and I was like,
"I think I could do that you know, you should let me try that."
By the end, I had done the whole thing
which was exciting.
That was cool.
You know what I didn't enjoy,
learning how to drive stick in 15 minutes
-Oh right!
so that Anthony could run into the car
while I was driving it.
The whole time I was just like,
"It's Anthony Mackie! It's
Anthony Mackie!"
"Don't kill Anthony Mackie!" You know?
-But I think it was okay.
-It worked!
-It worked perfectly.
-It worked great!
Hang on.
Thanks for the warning.
The most fun was driving
through the mall.
So if I'm here, then the exit is...
Oh, they have a Foot Locker!
And they're like, "Oh well you know
we wanna grab these shoes and
do this and do that
and you know just don't hit the wall."
I'm like, "I'm not gonna hit
the wall, I can drive."
So I can literally say I
drove through a mall
and scooped some shoes off the rack.
I think the great thing about
John is he's so...
angelic in the way he looks at life.
He's such a simple guy.
He thinks he has it all figured out
and with that comes a certain
naivety that he has
that really gives a spark to his
character that you never really see
and kinda takes the frustration
out of something like an apocalypse.
What I love too about like
I remember our early
conversations about John--
-Oh!
-Ah, double death.
-Nope!
Was that...
I think we're both...no you killed me!
-I think you died under me!
-You killed me!
Haha!
That was cool!
You wanna do multiplayer again?
-No no no, I'm going one player, you talk.
-Oh, you’re going one player.
You do it, you do it.
So Sweet Tooth in the games,
he's always been like a maniac
and he's never had a ton of backstory
and I think it was really fun
to like really build up
Sweet Tooth as like a fully
dimensional character
and shooting those scenes was
like an absolute blast.
Here for the show?
I'm definitely here for the show!
What was it like for you
Anthony working with Joe?
Because you guys had
fight scenes together.
Well yeah, I mean it hurt but...
I'm like, "Dude, you realize I'm not
250 pounds or your size, right?"
He's like "yeah yeah sure
sure sure, anyway..."
And then working with Thomas,
how was that for you guys?
He's phenomenal I think in this.
He's absolutely terrifying.
And then I spit in his face that one time.
-Oh my god
-Remember when I accidentally...
Whoa! Why'd you do that?
And he was very gracious about it.
He was so nice.
That was... that was a
real moment for me.
We'll revisit that attitude in a few hours.
Can't wait.
I think the great thing about this
show is it's an escape.
It's cars, it’s explosions,
it's comedy.
It's really fun
and it's grounded in performances
that feel really real.
And you got to learn how to drive stick.
-And I got to learn how to drive stick, yeah.
-So that's the whole point.
I want the audience to come
away from this saying,
"Wow, she learned how to
drive stick for that role."
She's cool.
-Now!